hey everyone I'm Richard and this is it
GTX 1060 the first of nvidia's
mainstream graphics cards based on its
new Pascal architecture priced at
$250 that puts it on collision course
with amd's radian
rx480 well kind of amd's 8 gig card is a
bit cheaper and has more memory while
the 4 gig card is a lot cheaper and
still a highly capable performer
nvidia's pitch for the 1060 is compared
though GTX 980 performance and that is a
pretty big deal it's not even 2 years
ago that the 980 was the latest and
greatest it launched in September 2014
as the new GPU king with a price point
to match
$550 now it was fast out of the box and
it overclocked like a demon and if
Nvidia can bring that kind of package to
the main stream well that's well worth
checking out so today I'm going to be
looking at this the Nvidia reference
card the Founders Edition styling wise
it shares the same design language as
the more expensive GTX 1070 and GTX 1080
and there's a definite sense of quality
to it Port selection on the rear is also
a match for the more expensive models
once again we have dual link DVI three
display ports and HDMI 2.0 good stuff
however the cheaper card gets a plastic
enclosure and one thing I wasn't too
impressed with was the complete lack of
SLI connector I think we could have got
some really interesting results from
this card in SLI and it does feel a
little mean-spirited of Nvidia to remove
this feature but for me the question is
this has Nvidia actually delivered on
its promise of GTX 980 performance well
based on our testing it seems that it
certainly does in some games but not so
much in others take a look at this
Assassin's Creed Unity 1080p ultra high
FXAA GTX 1060 is off offing a tight lock
here on GTX 980 performance and here in
Far Cry Primal we can see that it's
actually a touch faster I mean nothing
gamechanging but it's showing that the
new card is capable of hitting its
required performance level and we see a
similar scenario here with The Witcher 3
now according to our benchmarks here GTX
1060 it's about 4% faster however in
other cases the results aren't quite as
impressive Crisis 3 here it's 11% faster
on GTX 9 80 and with rise of the Tomb
Raider on dx12 the 980 has a 7%
Advantage so yeah by and large I'd say
well you are getting a GTX 980 style
experience but there will be games where
the 1060 is a little off the pace but
it's the rx480 that's going to be
nvidia's biggest Challenger here so how
does performance stack up there you're
looking at around 11 to 12% of
additional performance with this card
RIS the 2 Tom Raider even with its new
async compute dx12 patch well the 1060
is still way ahead there but games that
work well on AMD Hardware can still see
the rx480 pull ahead yes Hitman on dx12
it runs 11% faster on the AMD card but
there are some interesting results even
in dx11 land so take a look at the
division here the GTX 1060 is faster but
only by around 3% now we're going to be
doing a lot more dx12 testing soon but
one thing that is clear is that nvidia's
Pascal architecture does indeed support
that all important asynchronous compute
feature so this well this is time spy
the new 3D Mark Benchmark built for
direct X12 from the ground up and yeah
we can run this bench with both async
compute on and off now we see a bigger
uplift on the AMD card with async
compute enabled and the end result is
that both cards achieve very very
similar scores so yeah more extended X12
testing between these two cards in
actual games should be fascinating okay
so I think we've kind of covered
everything here there is no knockout
blow for AMD here with the GTX 1060 this
new product it costs a bit more but on
balance I kind of think you get a bit
more it's a fair deal for an impressive
product but it's not a GameChanger but
one area where it does fall short is in
terms of memory allocation now it's 8
gigs for AMD with the rx480 and six for
NVIDIA with the GTX 1060 here now the
question is of course does that actually
matter well the bottom line is that
right now even 4 gigs is enough for
1080p gaming the market where GTX 1060
is really targeted and that's kind of
reflected in all of the benchmarks we
carried out really but there are some
scenarios where more memory is a
requirement and none more so The
Mirror's Edge and its hyper mode running
that head-to-head with rx480 Nvidia is
still ahead despite the mammoth vram
requirement but regardless hyper mode
really is overkill and adds little to
The Mirror's Edge experience I think the
bottom line is this really if future
proofing is more important to you than
improved performance in the Here and Now
go for the rx480 otherwise the GTX 1060
looks like a pretty good deal and it's
much more amable to overclocking on this
Founders Edition I could add 210 MHz to
the core and RAM could be pushed up to 9
gbits per second and overall this adds
anything from 11 to 15% of additional
performance and it's ridiculously easy
to get this OC I think the bottom line
there is that 1060 kind of works more as
a GTX 970 replacement more performance
more RAM better efficiency and with a
discount on top and let's conclude with
a quick look at Power efficiency here
now our x480 it's not bad but GTX 1060
is handing in a considerable Improvement
more performance then and lower energy
consumption okay so look that's where
we're at for now do remember to check
out the SES of benchmarks we have
available for GTX 1060 going live with
this review we'll be keeping up with all
the new GPU launches so do subscribe to
digital Foundry to ensure you don't miss
a thing that's all for now thanks for
watching